what was it like kicking ass in TMI and
how did you prepare for that it was so
fun I loved action and I never thought
that I'd be doing stunts and movies but
the training was intense we had about
three months of physical training
beforehand and then during filming it
was every single day with the stunt
Department and you know physical fitness
like five in the morning 4:00 in the
morning before work but it was really
fun because in the end it pays off
because you get to see that we actually
are fighting and the Shadowhunter guys
had a bit more difficult than I did
because I only learn I have skills in
half way through the movie but all of
them I mean they really kick ass and it
was it was really fun I can't wait for
the sequel because I get to do more of
that Wow and what was it like stepping
into such a world of series and
character and one that you were a fan of
yourself yeah that was a complete honor
to play a character that I've that I'd
admired in the books and I love fantasy
I always have but I love that there's a
realness to this series that Cassandra
wrote but that also Harold used in the
directing of it and it's a film or you
know we're doing the sequel as well but
I think it's a series of books that
really is different than others because
it is so based in reality that it
doesn't take itself too seriously in the
fantasy world so it's a bit more
relatable to everybody and like a day to
day life what can fans expect and do you
think the the end will be as it is in
that first books it's quite interesting
it leaves you wondering about a very
important question which I you know if
you've read the books you've read the
books and you know but it's it's
something that was very difficult to
deal with in a film I think especially
when you're tipping it at the first one
I'm wondering if it's gonna be a second
one and you have to play it both ways
and it's a very sensitive topic but I
think we do so in a way that really
leaves you wanting more but at the same
time doesn't leave you completely
dumbfounded but I'm really I'm really
really excited I think the fans are
gonna be very happy I know the
expectations are set so high when there
are so many fans of the books but I
think we've we've done a really good job
of kind of balancing that
you